18 veces había denunciado a su
maltratador y 18 años tenía a úrsula
bahíllo en el momento de su asesinato
fue el 8 de febrero tras ser atacada con
un cuchillo por su expareja su madre
pide justicia y en memoria de mi hija
que tuve arriba del cajón
rezando la constantemente se lo prometí
a ella que voy hacer justicia el
miércoles miles de mujeres salieron a
las calles de argentina al grito de ni
una menos
[Música]
una proclama que ya es un movimiento en
un país en el que una mujer es asesinada
cada 29 horas y que desde el 1 de enero
cuenta con 50 muertes violentas de
mujeres trans y travestis según el
'observatorio mujeres de la materia
latinoamericana
datos que se transforman en una demanda
basta
las peticiones han llegado a la casa
rosada el presidente alberto fernández
anunció que el gobierno avanza para
crear un consejo federal para el
abordaje de los feminicidios travestis y
dios y trans feminicidios también pidió
a los gobernadores unidad contra la
violencia de género y recibió a los
padres de úrsula bahíllo alberto
fernández me escuchó con ma
me voy totalmente
[Música]
contenta a pesar de la tristeza que
tiene mi alma
el presidente
se ha comprometido con nosotros un
compromiso institucional presionado
desde las calles